bonsoir est-ce que chez vous peut-être
et on a de la place pour accueillir de
voyageurs de passage genre près du four
à pain là où il fait bien chaud
[Rires]
on met dedans les cendrier en tant que
fumeur non moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec mon conjoint si que moi je suis une
grosse fumeuse et je ne fume pas ni dans
les années de camping ni à l'extérieur
de la terrasse ou du resto peu importe
mais nulle part je suis parti ce matin
pendant deux heures et j'ai pas pris mes
clubs parce que c'est trop dangereux et
est-ce que par exemple des femmes vous
demandent comment puis-je me débarrasser
de mon mari oh oui c'est fréquent à
vice-versa est-ce que vous donnez des
recettes jamais
[Musique]
entre nous est-ce que c'est pas pour ça
qu'on les aime les femmes aussi elles
ont d'autres atouts
c'est quoi ce truc on dirait un impôts
de chasseur pour attirer des canards
c'est quoi quand ça fait pas de poète
mais ce pouet pouet pouet Patrice c'est
pas possible
faut que le sujet
vous voulez aborder la casse par semaine
la visite en France du président des
Émirats arabes unis Mohamed Benzaïd la
dernière venue d'un chef émirati remonte
à 1991 François Mitterrand était alors
président de la République mbz comme il
est surnommé des jeunes aujourd'hui en
tête-à-tête avec Emmanuel Macron oh que
c'est tout mignonet tout ça n'oubliez
jamais à l'heure où l'antisémitisme tue
encore nous devons par tout moyen faire
savoir faire connaître
faire connaître les formes que prennent
le racisme et l'antisémitisme c'est
justement l'objectif d'un rapport rendu
public aujourd'hui comment cohabitent
les Séfarades et les ashkéna c'est ça se
passe comment il y a pas de ségrégation
on n'a pas les mêmes racines on n'a pas
la même culture mais et alors j'ai cru
comprendre quand même que ça se charrier
un petit peu entre bon pas le même
humour voilà les ashkéna c'est plutôt un
numéro 2e degré tu vois un peu faim etc
un peu moins
les pieds dans le plat quoi on y apprend
que la proportion de Français se
déclarant par raciste du tout est en
hausse presque constante depuis des
années de 39% en 2013 le taux s'établit
à 63% aujourd'hui ça va pour vous
bien mais maintenant qu'on est un peu
plus léger je vous propose de reprendre
le chemin
sur la même période le nombre d'actes
racistes a pourtant continué à augmenter
atteignant même un record absolu selon
les chiffres du renseignement
territorial voilà ces climati pano il y
a 80 ans les collaborationsnistes du
régime Vichy ont organisé la rafle du
Vél d'Hiv' ne pas oublier ses crimes
aujourd'hui puisque jamais avec un
président de la République qui rend
honneur à Pétain et 89 députés RN et
j'ai vécu très mal le tweet de Mathilde
panot parce qu'elle joue avec ceux avec
quoi on ne devrait jamais jouer
la douleur des mémoires joue avec ça
c'est sortir du champ de la politique
c'est sortir du champ de la démocratie
[Musique]
je me suis réservé c'est la politique de
la France insoumise le bruit la fureur
en permanence le mensonge la
manipulation les excès moi je ne suis
pas parmi ces je n'ai pas des pudeurs de
gazelle je me souviens que Emmanuel
Macron avait eu des propos extrêmement
bizarres sur Pétain à qui il avait en
effet à moitié rendu hommage en
expliquant qu'il avait aussi été un
grand soldat enfin tout un truc
complètement birdificoté
un petit Jacques et moi je suis la
petite rose qui se noie ça fait plaisir
parce que on est même pas ensemble que
le mec il me protège déjà pour le coup
franchement merci Théo